cent ans après la grande guerre il ne
reste plus aucun combattant survivant
pourtant l'émotion des commémorations
reste intacte comme ici dans la ville
d'elancourt ou des élèves de cm2 ont
rendu hommage aux poilus à travers la
lecture de leur mémoire car il
décrit ce qu'il découvre il y avait là
dans le fossé deux ans après son hommage
certains se tenait la boj la boue devant
l'éternel là encore il y en avait qui
ils ont travaillé en fait avec notamment
les ipad les nouveaux outils dont ils
ont fait leurs propres recherches et on
a regardé ça ensemble et chaque groupe a
pu travailler vraiment sur une partie
spécifique de cette fameuse guerre et
puis là le devoir de mémoire pour voir
qu'en fait la liberté elle se paye aussi
au prix du sang elancourt avait perdu
onze de ses hommes pendant le conflit
mais l'hommage de vendredi ne
s'adressait pas seulement aux victimes
de la première guerre mondiale beaucoup
dans l'assemblée pensait à fabien
jacques le militaire trappistes tués au
mali il y a dix jours on a bien sûr
plusieurs soldats ici qui ont participé
aux opérations qui sont morts pour repo
défendre nos libertés il faut le
rappeler c'est ça aussi la solidarité 17
millions de morts pour la première
guerre mondiale 40 à 60 pour la seconde
des chiffres vertigineux qui nous
rappelle chaque année que la paix a été
obtenue à grands frais